just the mention of his name can send a
chill up the spine in a place full of
horror he was the most feared monster of
them all we're of course talking about
the Angel of Death Josef Mengele
although trained as a doctor to preserve
life he brought a sadistic cruelty to
the experiments that ended the lives of
so many and his victims of choice when
they were children in this week's by
graphics we reveal the depraved life of
the monster of Auschwitz dr. Josef
Mengele yes if Mengele entered the world
on the 16th of March 1911 in the German
Bavarian town of goons burg after three
miscarriages he was the first born of
Karl and well Perga Mengele karl was the
owner of a farm machine factory which
turned to producing munitions when war
broke out in 1914 the manglers would go
on to have two more sons but Joseph was
the firm favorite of his mother while
poker was an obese woman who had a Stern
reputation and a voracious appetite she
doted on her eldest son who was much
closer to him than she was to her
husband for his part Josef proved to be
a quiet child whose main goal was to
please his overbearing mother at school
Josef he was an average student he
struggled to keep his grades up at the
standard that his mother expected and
when he was fifteen he contracted the
serious bone marrow disease
osteomyelitis the disease which was
often fatal in those days kept him off
school for six months returning to class
he was seriously behind his peers
academically over the next two years he
showed a remarkable level of
self-discipline to not only catch up but
surpass many of his fellow students by
the age of 17 he had outgrown his
shyness and developed into a handsome
focused and driven young man who was
popular with both teachers and
classmates
you
in April 1930 the 19 year old passed his
high school exams and gained acceptance
into the medical and philosophy
faculties at Munich University he had
decided to become a doctor Mengele stood
out from the other men on campus
he was always impeccably dressed and had
developed the air of a gentleman he
treated women with old-fashioned dignity
and was a very good dancer all these
traits got him quickly noticed by the
ladies with the results that his social
calendar was usually pretty full during
his first year of university Mengele
began to show an interest in politics he
joined the steel helmets in March of
1931 a paramilitary group who advocated
a return to the pre-war monarchy the
steel helmets were a stepping stone in
the National Socialist or Nazi Party
which was promoted in beer halls as well
as on university campuses the Nazis
advocated a return of German pride and
pureness and the removal of racial
impurities these ideas they appealed to
Mengele and seemed to mesh with the
social Darwinism that he thought was
being taught in the lecture halls he
became fascinated with eugenics
particularly the idea that a population
could be made more perfect through
selective breeding of those who had the
most desirable characteristics it would
also help to weed out undesirable traits
by the elimination of the weak and the
feeble
while the Nazis believed in eugenics for
them the process of generational
selective breeding it was too slow they
were determined to weed out the weak
right now
the Aryan race could simply no longer
stands being contaminated by inferior
races such as the Slavs
and the Jews both of whom were
considered untermensch
or subhuman these beliefs were
enthusiastically embraced by the young
and impressionable Josef Mengele in 1935
Mengele was awarded a PhD in
anthropology his thesis was entitled
racial morphological research on the
lower jaw section of four
racial groups the paper was free of any
racial bias and set out to prove
empirically by science alone that the
German was a superior breeding and a
better human being
a year later Mengele graduated with a
medical degree he's been for months an
intern at Leipzig University clinic
before joining the staff of Germany's
leading racial expert this was dr. omar
free her von versa and he was based at
the Institute for heredity biology and
racial purity located at the University
of Frankfurt Mandela's job at the
Institute was to examine people who were
suspected of breaking the Nuremberg Laws
to see whether or not they were Jews he
and his colleagues created thousands of
files which would turn out to be
devastating in future years when people
were rounded up for transportation to
concentration camps in May of 1937
Mengele officially joined the Nazi Party
he became a member of the Nazi doctors
party and then in May of 1938 the shoot
Staffan or SS the SS had been created as
Hitler's personal protection squad but
it expanded its role to the running of
concentration camps the leader of the SS
was Heinrich Himmler a meticulous
organiser who had plans to make the
still small organization as powerful as
the national army at the time Mengele
joined the SS was an elite group that
only allowed the best specimens of Aryan
manhood into its ranks
[Music]
at about the same time as he became a
member of the SS Mangler became engaged
to Irene show in mind the daughter of a
professor at Frankfurt University six
years younger than Joseph Irene was a
blonde haired beauty and made the
perfect compliments to the handsome
athletic looking young doctor when it
came to getting married however there
was a bit of a problem while Yosef was
able to show documentation of his Aryan
purity Irene could not prove that her
grandfather was 100% Aryan it was only
the influence of the Mangala family that
smoothed the way for the wedding which
took place in July of 1939 the failure
to fully prove Irene's ancestry
precluded the manglers from inclusion in
the kinship book of the SS which
included couples who could prove their
Aryan ancestry back to 1750 as a result
Mengele was deprived of the swords and
spoons wort which was given to an SS man
on the birth of a child after his three
months of marriage Mengele was called
for a three-month stint in the Army he
was sent to the Tyrolean mountain region
possessing a high level of physical
fitness and being an adept hiker he
excelled in his service having completed
his three-month service he returned to
his job at Frankfurt University but with
the coming of war in 1939 national
mobilization was instituted Mengele was
rejected on the first draft because he
had had a kidney infection as a child
[Music]
in June of 1940 Mengele was finally
called up becoming a second left tannins
in the waffen-ss he was put in a no
combat position working in the
genealogical section of the race and
resettlement office by June of 1941 with
the onset of Operation Barbarossa there
was an urgent need for men to serve on
the Eastern Front Mengele was pulled out
of the office and sent to the Russian
front he proved to be a courageous
soldier winning the Iron Cross second
class at the beginning of 1942 Mengele
transferred to the Scandinavian Viking
SS division where he served as a field
doctor again he proved discouraged under
fire winning the Iron Cross first class
when he pulled two men from a burning
tank in November of 1942 he suffered
serious wounds and was taken off the
frontlines after a period of recovery he
returned to the race and resettlement
office he gained a promotion to captain
and then in mid 1943 was given what was
to him a dream job this was a practical
eugenics researcher this meant that he
was able to indulge all of the wackiest
eugenics theories testing them out on
living human subjects the human subjects
who would be mangle as guinea pigs were
to be found at the auschwitz-birkenau
concentration camp he obtained posting
to the camp and set about extending his
anthropological research into heredity
Mengele was not the first doctor to use
concentration camp inmates for research
purposes in Birkin vault and de Cao Jews
were injected with bacteria exposed to
all manner of deadly diseases and struck
with rifle buds repeatedly to see how
long it would take for them to suffer
irreversible brain damage at Auschwitz
itself doctor Horst Schumann had been
conducting sterilization experiments
once castrating 90 men in a single day
yes Mengele was to take the scope and
barbarity of his experiments to an
entirely new level outfits had been
elected as the venue for his work
because of its out-of-the-way location
and because it was close to a railway
junction with tracks coming from all
over Europe Mengele arrived at Auschwitz
on the 23rd of May 1943 the next day he
participated in his first selection this
involved selecting which of the new
inmate arrivals were to live and which
were to die on that day alone he sent
1035 gypsies to the gas chamber as was
his nature Mengele was
actively dressed during these selections
he wore a white SS medical uniform white
gloves and polished black boots his face
was emotionless as he decided who is to
die by a simple flick of his wrist his
constant chain-smoking and air of
nonchalance presented a mystifying yet
terrifying sight for the bewildered new
arrivals during his time at Auschwitz
Mengele oversaw selection on 74
transports 80% of new arrivals were
condemned to death immediately all
children under the age of 14 were killed
as with the old in the infer Mandela
seemed to enjoy this aspect of his job
and he was known to say here the Jews
and through the doors and leave through
the chimney mangle is passion however
was for scientific research he
instructed the guards to seek out those
who were deformed overly tall midgets or
he will aim his most prized subjects
were twins especially if they were
children from his earliest days at
university Mangala had a fascination
with twins
he believed that by studying them he
could discover the secret to genetic
manipulation indeed it was his search
for twins that motivated him to attend
so many arrival selections during his
time at Auschwitz he managed to find
1500 pairs of twins that were used as
human guinea pigs only 100 pairs
survived the twins and other research
subjects who were selected on arrival
would be marched to living quarters at
the Birkenau about 2 miles away there
they lived in appalling conditions
surrounded by rotting corpses and
starving adults once established in
their disgraceful living quarters the
children had to complete an intensive
questionnaire in which they had to
indicate their age height eye and hair
color ethnic backgrounds as well as any
health problems older children assisted
young ones to complete performs
desperate to have everything completed
to the satisfaction of the guards
children would then be interviewed by a
Mangler himself who would take extensive
notes and then have a file for each
child drawn up he was determined to have
his research seen as legitimate and so
he went to great lengths to keep
everything official in preparation for
experimentation the children were
cleaned bathed and dressed in clean
pajamas
they were then taken by Red Cross
vehicles to one of Mandela's research
laboratories he had established a number
of labs around the auschwitz-birkenau
area for these specific purposes at one
blood tests and x-rays were taken here
the children were treated with care
Mengele would come in regularly to make
sure that none were being mistreated on
these
agency would hand out sweets to the
children and talk gently and
reassuringly to them by doing this he
was able to engender trust which got the
children onto his experimentation table
[Music]
in other labs the most heinous barbarism
was taking place on a daily basis
anesthesia was never used so the pain
that was inflicted on the children can
hardly even be imagined experiments
included the removal of specific organs
or limbs immersion in freezing water the
injection of dyes and the eyes the
castration of boys sterilization of
girls and deliberate infection of wounds
with gangrene occasionally Mengele would
organize endurance test experiments this
involved subjects being given
increasingly strong voltages of
electricity until they either died
became unconscious or went into a coma
as soon as a twin died its sibling would
immediately be killed in order to
provide comparative data during the
autopsies
despite manglers attempts to cloak his
work in legitimacy there was no valid
scientific reason for any of these
horrendous experiments doctors who
assisted Mengele later recorded that it
seemed as if many of the experiments
were just inspired purely by sadism in
addition to his diabolical lab work into
selection duties with new arrivals
Mengele occasionally delivered babies
women who were found to be pregnant were
immediately gassed however if they were
near full-term Mengele would deliver the
baby only to be sent with its mother to
death one of his greatest amusements was
to allow for them both to live for some
time but to tape the mothers breasts so
that she would be forced to watch her
baby starve to death of all of his
atrocities the worst occurred when he
had a pit dug and a massive violet in
the yard of Birkenau he then had 300
children all under the age of 5 thrown
into the flames unlike the majority of
Nazi killers Mengele did not have to be
drugged or drunk in order to carry out
his murderous work in fact according to
Jewish survivors who were forced to
assist in the laboratory's he was
enthusiastic in his infliction of
Cruelty at times his temper would flare
and exhibit itself with sharp bursts of
horror on one occasion he smashed an old
man's skull Akande simply because he
wanted to be on his son's work detail
within the camps of auschwitz and
birkenau Mengele had unlimited power
this combined with his natural sadism
turned him into a monster
he was often accompanied on his rounds
his female equal SS goddamn aggressor a
21 year old blonde beauty who was almost
as depraved as he was the two of them
marched around the camp in immaculate
uniform the perfect Aryan couple Mangal
has hatred for the Jews knew no bounds
he would celebrate Jewish holy days such
as Yom Kippur by ordering the gassing of
a thousand children but his extreme
prejudice could not prevent feelings of
lust from arising within him on occasion
went naked young women were paraded in
front of him on one occasion a beautiful
15 year old Jewish girl from
Transylvania stood in front of him
Mengele was clearly aroused by the girl
obviously torn inside he and the girl
selected for special experimentation
over the next hour he caused such
deformity to her body that she resembled
an old decrepit hag he then left her to
die having overcome his illicit lust by
early 1944 Mengele had taken to adopting
a child invariably the little boy would
physically resemble him and would be
dressed in a small white medical uniform
Mengele would walk around the camp and
in hands with the child providing him
with sweets and toys within a month the
doctor would tire of the child and let
him still hand in hand to the gas
chamber the cruel of the Mengele was in
the conducting of his duties the more
respect he got in the Nazi hierarchy in
a report written at the end of 1944 out
of its camp commandant Rudolf Hess wrote
that Mengele carried out all tasks even
Zim often under very difficult
conditions to the complete satisfaction
of his superiors often using his little
off-duty time to utilize the scientific
material at his disposal to make
valuable contribution to anthropological
science
[Music]
by early 1945 Mengele was at the height
of his power
yet he could also read the writing on
the wall he knew that the war was soon
lost and that the Russians would overrun
the camp in early January the crematoria
had been blown up and healthy prisoners
were being forced marched to new
destinations in Germany Mengele
continued his experiments until the last
minute but then he busied himself in
shipping out all of his equipment
documents and reports then on January
the 17th of 1945 Joseph Mengele simply
disappeared from Auschwitz ten days
later the Russians arrived they
discovered a burnt-out horror Factory
the place had been set on fire and the
Germans like Mengele at flat a few
thousand survivors more dead than alive
were found wandering among the ruins
Mengele had fled to another
concentration camp further south then as
the Russians closed in on that camp he
made for the math housing camp in
Austria when the Allies approached he
ditched his Nazi uniform and went on the
run his freedom it didn't last long on
May the second he had joined up with a
war hospital units the unit soon was
overrun by the Russians and all the
Germans were taken into custody when
arrested main hello was wearing a
Wehrmacht uniform he proved to be a bad
prisoner constantly worrying that he
would be exposed as an SS officer with
all of the suspected SS men weeded out
he and the other prisoners were handed
over to the Americans and then released
the angel of death appeared to have
escaped scot-free
however he knew he would be constantly
hunted down he was too afraid to return
to his family so he travelled around
West Germany and into Soviet occupied
East Germany for three years he worked
as a labourer on an Alpine farm in
Bavaria
[Music]
meanwhile the story of menglers
atrocities have been revealed to the
world at large as a result he became the
most sought after Nazi scalp by post-war
Nazi hunters he made the decision to
flee Europe walking over the absent
crossing into Italy in April of 1949 he
then made his way to South Tyrol where
he managed to obtain an International
Red Cross ID card under a false name
with this he managed to get a Swiss
passport Mengele then travelled to Genoa
where he set sail for Buenos Aires
Argentina upon arriving on Argentinean
soil Mengele finally felt safe he was
taken in by argentinian President Juan
Peron and lived within his palatial
compound Iran had been a long time
supporter of Hitler and it opened up his
country to fleeing Nazis Mengele
established a comfortable life in
Argentina he found work as a carpenter a
trader which he proved to be adept he
was also a highly respected member of
the local Nazi community by now his
father was extremely wealthy as a result
of his business ventures the old man
financed international rendevouz usually
at skiing resource absent from these
family get-togethers was manglers wife
Irene who had divorced her husband in
absent Esha on a family skiing trip to
Switzerland in 1956 Mengele charmed his
dead brother calls widow Martha a year
later they were married Martha and her
son Rolf moved to Argentina to be with
Mengele with the backing of his father's
money Mengele and his new family they
lived very well they moved into an
upmarket villa in a luxurious suburb
ironically in the midst of many wealthy
Jewish families he felt so confident in
his new life that in 1956 he gave up his
alias and reverted to his real name
however a determined handful of Nazi
hunters mainly made up of Holocaust
survivors were hot on his trail one of
them Hermann Lange beam managed to get a
hold of the divorce papers filed by
Irene they indicated that man Halle was
living in Buenos Aires Lange been
pressured the West German government to
issue an arrest warrant which they did
on June the 7th 1959 the West German
Foreign Ministry now demanded that
Mengele be extradited to face the
charges
[Music]
megalo was warned what was happening and
fled to Paraguay a year later he moved
on to Brazil where he settled in with a
Hungarian couple on a small farm about
300 miles from Sao Paulo in mid 1962 he
moved again this time to a 45 hectare
farm at sierra negra 150 miles north of
sal power where he bordered with the
strauss a family in his old age
Mengele became arrogant surly and
self-centered he treated other people
there's his intellectual and racial
inferiors in 1964 a war crime trial for
Mengele was held in absentee shep
throughout the course of the trial the
gruesome details of his experiments were
related often by surviving human guinea
pigs as a result of these revelations he
became a hated figure for the vast
majority of West Germans
by 1970 the efforts to get Mengele
extradited had petered out and he had
largely been forgotten about he
continued to live an unhappy life with
the Strasser family who had grown to
loathe him in 1976 he suffered a stroke
from which he only partially recovered
he finally met his end in February of
1979 suffering a fatal stroke while
swimming at the beach and bertioga until
the moment he took his last breath he
never uttered a single regret about his
actions at Auschwitz so I really hope
you enjoyed that by graphics video if
you did don't forget to subscribe to
this channel for brand new biographies
every Monday and Thursday also I've got
another channel it's called top tens on
that channel as you might have guessed
from the name of it we look at all sorts
of interesting top 10 lists you can
check it out through the link on the
screen now but if you're looking for
something else to watch right now why
not check out a biography from the
archives or indeed a top tens video over
there on the right and as always thank
you for watching